das ist Christoph Jentsch und im Jahr
2016 hat er einen Code veröffentlicht
der das Internet für immer verändern
sollte
es war ein Computer Code für eine
revolutionäre neue Idee er sollte die
Regeln des Internets neu schreiben er
sollte Firmen und Organisationen auf der
ganzen Welt umkrempeln aber bekannt ist
Christophs Code vor allem aus einem
anderen Grund er wurde gehackt in einem
Kampf um 150 Millionen Dollar in einem
der größten internetkrimis aller Zeiten
das ist eine Geschichte über
kryptowährungen und damit über einen
riesigen Markt
2016 hatte der globale Markt an
kryptowährungen noch einen Wert von 7
Milliarden Euro Ende 2021 waren es 2,6
Billionen
dieses ganze Geld das ist sicher
gespeichert auf der blockchain wo die
man dran kommt zumindest soll das
niemand
[Gelächter]
aber jetzt stell dir mal ein
Geldautomaten vor auf den ersten Blick
funktioniert er wie jeder andere
du gibst ein dass du ein Hunderter
willst tippst deine PIN ein fertig aber
das war nur der erste Blick auf den
zweiten hast Du herausgefunden dieser
spezielle Automat hat eine Schwäche
nachdem du dein hunderte abgehoben hast
kannst du das den Automaten vergessen
lassen und dann kannst du die gleichen
hundert noch mal abheben als wäre die
erste Auszahlung nie passiert du tust
das wieder und wieder immer wieder hebst
du denselben Betrag ab obwohl dein Konto
schon längst leer sein sollte
das perfekte Verbrechen das war die
Methode eines blockchain Hacks am 17
Juni 2016 an diesem Tag beginnt ein
Unbekannter die Geldreserven des bis
dahin größten blockchain-projekts
überhaupt anzuzapfen
150 Millionen Dollar stehen auf dem
Spiel und niemand kann ihn aufhalten das
ist die Geschichte von einem der größten
hackerraub-züge jemals und darüber was
er für die Zukunft des Internets
bedeutet das ist die Geschichte der DAU
[Musik]
ja mein Name ist Christoph Jentsch ich
komme hier aus Mittweida ich bin
Familienmensch selber sieben Kindern ich
bin Entwickler
vor fast zehn Jahren macht Christoph
Jentsch eine Entdeckung im Internet und
auch wenn er es da noch nicht weiß wird
diese Entdeckung sein Leben verändern ja
das war wäre meine doktorandenzeit
ungefähr Sommer 2013 fand ein paar
vorneinträge hier mal im blockpos dazu
und eben das Whitepaper
Satoshi nakamoto ist eines der größten
Rätsel des Internets wer hinter diesem
Namen steckt ist ein Geheimnis wer auch
immer es ist veröffentlicht Ende 2008
ein Whitepaper einen Leitfaden für eine
dezentrale Währung die ohne Staat und
ohne Banken funktioniert er nennt sie
Bitcoin
ich habe mich schon im Studium sehr für
selbstorganisierte Systeme aus selbst
organisierende Systeme interessiert so
alles was man oft Natur auffindet wo es
keine klaren Führer gibt aber Ameisen
oder viele andere hat man es oft ja die
organisieren sich selbst und das habe
ich immer fasziniert ein Bitcoin war für
mich genauso ein System
Bitcoin funktioniert durch eine
Technologie namens blockchain
eine blockchain ist eine Datenbank die
alles mögliche dokumentieren kann im
Fall von Bitcoin dokumentiert sie wer
wie viel Bitcoin besitzt und wer wem
seine Bitcoin weiterschickt
anders als eine normale Datenbank wird
eine blockchain aber nicht nur auf einem
einzelnen Rechner abgespeichert sondern
auf tausenden Rechnern gleichzeitig
jeder speichert eine komplette Kopie der
Datenbank die sich permanent
aktualisiert das heißt wenn jemand
versucht die Datenbank zu fälschen sich
selber mehr Bitcoin zuzuschieben als er
eigentlich hat dann können alle anderen
Rechner einspringen und ihn über stimmen
die Aufzeichnungen der blockchain lassen
sich also nicht fälschen
es sei denn mehr als die Hälfte der
weltweiten Bitcoin Rechenleistung
fälscht gleichzeitig auf die gleiche
Weise und das ist die Technologie die
die Welt verändern kann sagen zumindest
Menschen wie Katharina Gera
als dann die Idee raufkam mit einer
blockchain kann ich dezentral ohne
intermediär und ohne staatliche Stelle
das Thema Währung organisieren das war
für mich der absolute Aha-Moment
Katharina Gehrer verwaltet einen Krypto
Hedgefonds leitet die blockchain
analysefirma im Youtuber Insight und
sitzt im Aufsichtsrat der Börse
Stuttgart das war absolut
Aufbruchstimmung das war aber auch
damals schon Verrücktheit
und es wird noch verrückter denn nach
Bitcoin folgt die nächste Idee bitcoin
ist eine blockchain mit der man
virtuelles Geld hin und herschieben kann
nicht mehr nicht weniger aber könnte man
auf der blockchain noch viel mehr tun
Verträge abschließen Unternehmen gründen
Kunst verkaufen alles ohne dass man
jemanden in der Mitte braucht der das
ganze autorisiert
[Musik]
das ist die Idee von Vitali butterriemen
und er nennt sie isserion
[Musik]
dann kam das ist hier im Wald paper raus
von vitalik ich weiß nicht wann ich
genau gelesen habe es kann sein es war
Dezember aber es war wahrscheinlich also
Januar Februar rum irgendwo in
irgendeinen Forum auf den Link gestoßen
und das hat mich wirklich extrem
fasziniert es ist transparent ich kann
sehen welche Abhängigkeit besteht es
steht eine Formel wenn X dann y wenn
Apfel mir gehört dann Eigentümerin
Katharina und diese Einfachheit diese
erzwungene Standardisierung und
Verständlichkeit die schafft etwas
universelles und die Möglichkeiten die
das innerhalb wollen wir eigentlich
nicht sagen sofort komplett klar aber
ich habe nur erahnen können was damit
möglich war ich habe mich damit noch
mehr beschäftigt und eine Sommer 2014
habe ich meinen Doktor pausiert bis
heute ehrlich gesagt und habe mich dann
ganz den gewidmet und habe da bei der
Islam Foundation angefangen zu arbeiten
ich hatte damals drei Kinder brauchte
noch mehr Geld ich hatte mehrere
Angebote gehabt von Firmen die mich als
Softwareentwickler freiberuflich nehmen
würden es gab eine sehr solide Firma aus
Stuttgart die als Software geschrieben
für das Bauwesen ganz solide im
Vergleich dazu dann ethereum zu Beginn
ist ethereum vor allem ein loses
Netzwerk von Entwicklern auf der ganzen
Welt die meisten Arbeiten von zu Hause
aber es gibt auch Räume wo die
Entwickler zusammenkommen einer davon
ist in Berlin auch Christoph Jentsch ist
oft dort
es ist mir so ein bisschen wie man hat
gefühlt wie eine Hippie-Kommune
eines Abends waren wir zu Besuch bei den
ethereum Entwicklern in Berlin ich weiß
noch genau da waren diese idealistischen
Hacker die haben diese fantastische
Technologie gebaut und ich habe mir
gedacht diese Leute verstehen nicht
wirklich wie die Welt funktioniert aber
trotzdem wusste ich sie werden die Welt
verändern
damals weiß noch niemand ob das mal
etwas wird mit dieser Idee ob sich die
Welt überhaupt für ethereum interessiert
bis zum Launch 2015
[Musik]
so hi mein Name ist Alex ich heiße Alex
van de Sande ich komme aus Brasilien ich
habe seit 2014 mit ethereum zu tun und
war dort einer der ersten Designer
was mich fasziniert ist je nachdem wo
man darüber spricht sehen die Leute sich
selbst darin reflektiert als ich in
Brasilien Präsentation gegeben habe da
haben die Leute über das Potenzial
gesprochen damit Korruption zu bekämpfen
in Frankreich darüber Bürokratie zu
bekämpfen und in den Vereinigten Staaten
ging es immer vor allem darum wie man
Unternehmen aufbauen kann die unabhängig
sind von der Regierung
für mich bedeutet es eine Community
aufbauen zu können ohne dass man dafür
eine große Plattform braucht die sich
zwischen und setzt und etwas von dem
Wert der Community abschöpft wenn wir
zwei auf Social Media befreundet sind
dann besitzen wir diese Beziehung
zwischen das nicht wirklich diese
Beziehung sitzt in einer Datenbank bei
einer techfirma
das Ziel hinter ethereum ist also auch
die Macht der großen tech-konzerne zu
verringern und zu dezentralisieren das
klingt erst einmal großartig aber
ethereum hat seine Kritiker die
blockchain ist zum Beispiel noch recht
langsam viel langsamer als ein
herkömmlicher Computer ihre Werkzeuge
werden immer wieder von Betrügern
benutzt und aktuell verbraucht sie noch
jede Menge Strom
aber trotzdem die Menschen die an
ethereum glauben die sind All-In macht
die blockchain zum neuen Internet
[Musik]
Christoph Jentsch bleibt nicht dauerhaft
bei ethereum irgendwann wechselt er
wieder in die Privatwirtschaft zusammen
mit seinem Bruder Simon gründet er ein
Unternehmen slogit und dabei entsteht
gleich eine weitere Idee die Idee für
die Christoph berühmt werden wird die
Dow da steht für dezentrale autonome
Organisation die Idee ist ist damals
gewesen 2016 oder 2015 um angefangen
haben jeder konnte Geld in Form von ETA
reinstecken bekommt raus einen toten so
was wie Anteile an dieser Organisation
nicht mitbekommen nicht schlimm wir
fangen einmal von vorne an stell dir
einmal vor das bist du und das ist dein
Chef der sagt dir was du zu tun hast und
über deinem Chef hat dein Chef natürlich
auch eine Chefin und die ist Chefin für
ganz viele andere Chefs gleichzeitig die
wiederum Chefs von ganz vielen Leuten
sowie du sind so kennen wir dieses
System jedes Unternehmen jede politische
Partei sogar jeder Fußballverein ist so
aufgebaut und das heißt auch wenn jemand
einen Chef hat der nicht ganz perfekt
ist dann leiden alle darunter wenn
jemand seine Verantwortung nicht ernst
nimmt wenn jemand unfreundlich ist wenn
jemand aus den falschen Gründen
befördert wird dann funktioniert das
alles nicht mehr wirklich also können
wir das ganze nicht mal anders denken
eine Organisation ohne Hierarchien ohne
Chefs bestehend nur aus Menschen und
Code möglich gemacht durch die
blockchain
das ist die Dow
und warum sollte man das Bauen
warum alles können und das war auch
schon manchmal der ganze Grund na wie
haben wir gar kein Geld verdient daran
also das muss man vielleicht auch sehen
auch ein großes Missverständnis ist auf
da ist wir haben nicht einen Euro jemals
dafür bekommen
und so soll die darauf funktionieren
wenn du in die Dauer hinein willst
kannst du dich einkaufen und zwar mit
Ether das ist die kryptowährung der
ethereum blockchain die kryptowährung
landet dann im großen Tresorraum der DAO
und jetzt kannst du dich mit anderen
austauschen und ihr könnt gemeinsam
entscheiden was mit dem Geld im
Tresorraum passieren soll vielleicht
wollt ihr in eine Geschäftsidee
investieren oder das Geld an eine gute
Sache Spenden oder vielleicht wollt ihr
es für Marketing ausgeben damit noch
mehr Leute von der DAO erfahren und noch
mehr Geld da ist
alles ist möglich und die daumitglieder
können alle zusammen abstimmen
[Musik]
aber was wenn Dir das Ergebnis einer
Abstimmung nicht gefällt
dann kannst du eine Tochter DAO eröffnen
eine Dauer in der DAO da kannst du dein
Geld wieder abheben und nach ein paar
Wochen Wartezeit darfst du es wieder mit
rausnehmen und damit machen was du
willst das soll die Dauer sein die
dezentrale autonome Organisation und
weil alle Transaktionen auf der ethereum
blockchain gespeichert werden gibt es
auch keine hinterzimmerdeals keine Chefs
die sich Geld abzwacken es gibt nur die
Community
[Musik]
am 30 April 2016 geht die DAU auf der
ethereum blockchain in Betrieb
noch hat niemand eine Ahnung wie viele
Leute ihr beitreten werden oder wie viel
Geld sie einsammeln wird
[Musik]
wir hatten Snack gehabt mit ungefähr
5.000 Nutzern wenn alle davon die da
drin sind 1.000 Euro geben da sind wir
aber ungefähr fünf Millionen aber es
kommt anders
man kann virale Effekte nicht planen die
gibt es einfach manchmal irgendwas geht
einfach viral und die Dauer ist einfach
viral gegangen und alle anderen
gesprochen alle haben darüber
geschrieben
ich war völlig überwältigt ich glaube
ich habe geklatscht als ich von der
Dauer erfahren habe ich habe direkt
einen Post darüber geschrieben der in
Brasilien viral gegangen ist es war
fantastisch
von New York Times gewesen
Sonntagsausgabe und zwar einfach völlig
überwältigt die Aufmerksamkeit ist
generiert hat was so enorm das
letztendlich ein etwa 150 Millionen
Dollar eingenommen worden was natürlich
niemand erwartet hat wirklich niemand ja
innerhalb eines Monats wird die Dauer
von einer obskuren Idee zur größten
Crowdfunding Kampagne aller Zeiten 150
Millionen Dollar bedeutet jeder siebte
coin der kryptowährung später liegt in
der DAU
[Musik]
dazu zu sehen wie die Dauer quasi jeden
Tag mehrere Millionen quasi auffällt
immer immer größer wurde immer größer
wurde das hat uns schon echt Angst
eingefusst was ist wenn diese Dauer ist
schlechte Sache finanziert Dinge für die
ich persönlich nicht stehe die moralisch
verwerflich sind oder andere Dinge und
ich bin damit mein Name irgendwo damit
verbunden will eigentlich gar nichts
mehr damit zu tun haben das zweite ist
die Double für immer leben für immer
existieren niemand kann sie jemals
stoppen so hatte ich Angst dass ich mir
irgendwann mal gehen würde dass ich dazu
beigetragen habe einen Monster zu
erschaffen worüber ich keine Kontrolle
mehr habe
es war ein Freitag morgen ich habe immer
sehr lange gearbeitet abends das heißt
manchmal ein bisschen näher geschlafen
meine Frau hat mich geweckt gesagt
ziehen wir uns am Telefon also mein
Bruder gemeint irgendwas ist nicht in
Ordnung
ich bin dann mein Büro runtergegangen
Laptop aufgeklappt damals ist das Scan
das ist so ein blockchain Explorer wo
man schauen kann was passiert gerade
habe ich reingeschaut aber mehr Geld
raus also reingesteckt hat das kann
nicht sein und dann war klar das ist ein
Hack ich jetzt gerade
ich war gerade aufgewacht in meiner
Wohnung in Rio de Janeiro und mein
Telefon war voller Nachrichten alles was
ich gleich merkte war dass es irgendwas
mit der Dauer zu tun hat und schließlich
drehe ich mich zu meiner Frau um und
sage hey erinnerst du dich wie ich dir
erzählt habe von diesem großen
unhackbaren Berg aus Geld ja der ist
gerade gehackt worden
also in dem Moment war mir klar Game
Over raus vorbei
so schnell geht es Christoph und sein
Team haben über ein halbes Jahr an der
DAU gearbeitet und in nur einem Moment
stirbt sie in dem nämlich
[Musik]
in dem ein Hacker die Schwäche der DAO
erkennt den einen Fehler im Code ja ich
erkenne das schon
also hier gibt es eigentlich los
burn-autokens hier ist es sowieso genau
diese Zeile
es war eine Zeile die gar nicht nötig
war in welcher Zeitpunkt
je nachdem wie man es zählt als ob man
jetzt die Kommentare mitzählt oder nicht
ist er tatsächlich ungefähr bei Zeile
666 was das ironische daran ist diese
Zeile haben viel zu lange alle übersehen
sie bedeutet wenn man weiß wie dann kann
man die Dauer austricksen und Geld
abheben dass man nie eingezahlt hat
als jemand erkennt wo der Fehler liegt
ist es schon zu spät
wenn du in der Zeit zurückreisen
könntest in deinen in deinen damaligen
code was müsstest du verändern wer das
wie welche unglaublich gigantischen
Veränderungen müssen
eine Zeile aus kommentieren und fertig
nur die DAO ist jetzt online und auf der
blockchain heißt das sie jetzt zu
verändern würde viel zu viel Zeit
brauchen also was tun
ich hatte selber Geld investiert jetzt
nicht viel vielleicht so viel dass es
für ein gebrauchtes Auto reichen würde
aber mir war schnell klar ich sollte
jetzt nicht einfach versuchen damit
abzuhauen ich sollte versuchen anderen
damit zu helfen
ungefähr 50 Millionen Dollar daraus
genommen und das lag ja noch 100
Millionen Dollar drin und jeder konnte
genau denselben Hack auch ausführen und
die auch rauszunehmen und es ist wie
wenn 100 Millionen auf der offene Straße
liegen und in den Käfig das Schloss ist
offen
und was macht man da
die Antwort bieten Alex van de Sander
und eine Gruppe von anderen Experten sie
Form eine Gruppe von White hat hacken
das sind Hacker die die gleichen
Methoden ihre bösen Kollegen benutzen
nur eben für die gute Seite am Anfang
waren uns die Konsequenzen ziemlich
schnuppe was hatten wir da eigentlich
vor was überhaupt legal was wir da taten
und was bedeutet hier überhaupt das Wort
legal ist es Diebstahl wenn man Geld
sichert das sonst jemand anderes stehlen
würde irgendwann haben wir dann gesagt
wir machen das jetzt einfach obwohl wir
das alles nicht wissen und dann
überlassen wir es den Anwälten
herauszufinden was wieder eigentlich
angestellt haben
was haben sie gewartet aber ist der
Angreifer weitergemacht hat langsam
scheinen für scheinen rauszuziehen haben
sich zwischenzeitlich vorbereitet und
hängt besser auszuführen
das heißt plötzlich regt sich etwas in
der Daro die Tresore werden immer Lehrer
immer mehr Geld wird abgezapft und
diesmal ist es nicht der Hacker die
Community ist schockiert ein zweiter
Angriff dann die Nachricht die da wird
sicher gelehrt keine Panik schreibt Alex
vanessande auf Twitter
wir mussten diese kleinen
split-funktionen für die Tochter der
ausnutzen die waren wie kleine
Rettungsboote stell dir vor die Titanic
geht unter und es gibt einen Haufen
Rettungsbote und du versuchst so viel
wie möglich auf eines der Boote
mitzunehmen
ich glaube wir haben fast alles was
möglich war gesichert der erste Hacker
hat ungefähr 30 Prozent ausgeräumt aber
alles andere haben wir uns geholt bis
auf den letzten Penny
nur was jetzt was ist mit den 30 Prozent
die der Hacker schon hat in der normalen
nicht digitalen Welt würde jetzt die
Polizei kommen aber hier in der DAO gibt
es keine Polizei es gibt keine Obrigkeit
keine Hierarchien es gibt nur den Code
und das bedeutet wenn alle ihr Geld
zurückbekommen wollen dann muss die
ethereum Community das tun was
eigentlich unmöglich sein sollte
sie muss die Zeit zurückdrehen wir
lassen alles wie es ist es lief ja alles
weiter es lief danach auch noch alles
weiter wir fassen nur diese Accounts an
die mir das zu tun haben solche
chirurgische Eingriff wir schneiden das
ganz sauber raus und packen das an eine
neue Stelle mit einem Code wo alle ihr
Geld zurückbekommen können und alles
andere läuft ganz einfach weiter nur
dieses Verfahren erfordert eine
sogenannte hard fork hier muss nicht
einfach nur die Dauer überschrieben
werden sondern die ethereum blockchain
selbst die angeblich unfehlbare
blockchain muss künstlich manipuliert
werden und das geht nur wenn die
Mehrheit der Community dafür ist doch
die Community ist gespalten wir wollen
den Menschen quasi mehr Souveränität
geben auch finanziell und deshalb war
das eigentlich gegen meine Prinzipien
diesen hart vor zu machen deshalb hat er
sich ein bisschen Gefühl dass wenn man
sein eigenes Baby irgendwo Schaden
zufügen wenn ethereum die Zukunft des
Internets ist dann entscheidet sich hier
wie dieses Internet aussehen soll
wird der Code über allem stehen oder
werden Menschen im Notfall auch
eingreifen können und sagen hier haben
wir einen Fehler gemacht
die Umfrage läuft und mit 81 Prozent
stimmt die Community für die hardwalk
alle Äther die sich in der Daube fanden
werden zurückgesetzt ihren
ursprünglichen Besitzern ausgehändigt es
ist eine Art Währungsreform eine neue
Version des kryptogeldes wird geschaffen
das geklaute alte Geld existiert weiter
ist aber viel weniger wert wie viel
genau weiß niemand
alles in allem würde ich sagen hat die
Geschichte jetzt hier gut getan auch
diesen Fall zu setzen das letztendlich
die Community das letzte Wort hat also
in ganz ganz ganz extremen Fällen die
man sich wahrscheinlich heute kaum
ausmalen kann und ich bin extrem
erleichtert darüber dass zumindestens
alle ihr Geld zurückbekommen haben das
war mir eigentlich das Wichtigste und
trotzdem ich dachte mein Name ist immer
verbrannt nach der Aktion es gab dann
das con 2 in Shanghai das war so die
einmal im Jahr kommt die ganze Erziehung
Community zusammen und ich sagte okay
ich musste einfach hingehen ich muss
mein Gesicht zeigen ich muss darüber
sprechen es gab es denn über welchen die
hat mich sehr sehr berührt das sehr sehr
lange mir eigentlich alle gezeigt haben
was wir super gemeister also super
gemeistert haben was danach ging ich
wurde mit offenen Armen empfangen und
bin auch heute noch Teil dieser
Community arbeite gerne in dieser
Industrie die DAO war zu ihrem Zeitpunkt
das größte ethereum Projekt aller Zeiten
sie sollte das Internet und ethereum
verändern und hätte es stattdessen fast
in Brand gesteckt der Versuch macht neu
zu organisieren
um den Computercode herumzubauen dieses
ganze Experiment ist gescheitert also
heute denke ich auch ein kleines
bisschen anders darüber als ich damals
schon gedacht habe Hierarchien sind für
viele Dinge sehr effizient und gut und
Hierarchien sind oft effizient und
schnell können Entscheidungen treffen
und Dinge umsetzen ja es ich freue mich
jedes Mal wenn ich sehe dass der Gedanke
weiterlebt moment mal weiterlebt war die
Dauer nicht ein riesenfiasko
weil ich glaube in fünf oder zehn Jahren
wird es komplett normal sein für eine
Dauer zu arbeiten oder mit einer DAO
mein Name ist Baas grasmeier ich komme
aus den Niederlanden arbeite auf der
ganzen Welt als digitalstratege aber
ohne zu reisen vor allem
[Musik]
onlines Lieblingsthema daraus und dabei
denkt er nicht an die DAO von Christoph
Jentsch sondern an all die die danach
kam
[Musik]
eine ziemlich berühmte Dauer auch wenn
es etwas albern klingt heißt dinnerdau
der wollte ein paar Leute einfach ein
Abendessen veranstalten einfach nur als
kleines Experiment aber das wurde zu
einem kulturellen Phänomen weil
plötzlich jede Menge Leute beitreten
wollten
wo es für mich wirklich klick gemacht
hat war bei einer Dauer Namen zauncamp
der bin ich sehr früh beigetreten auch
das war erst einmal ein Experiment wir
erstellen Kunst und Musik und am Schluss
verkaufen wir das ganze als NFP als
digitales Kunstwerk
das heißt die Künstlerinnen und Künstler
haben erstmal gratis Songs erstellt aber
mit dieser Methode haben sie es trotzdem
geschafft viel Geld einzunehmen
hätten sie die Musik einfach auf
Streaming-Diensten veröffentlicht dann
hätte es wahrscheinlich zehn Jahre
gedauert um die gleiche Summe zusammen
zu bekommen
überall im internetexperimentieren heute
krypto-fans damit macht in darus neu zu
verteilen es gibt eine klimadao die
CO2-Zertifikate kaufen will eine
freistow die ein fast food-restaurant
eröffnen möchte eine Ukraine Dauer mit
der die Gründerin der Band pussy Riot
Geld für die Ukraine gesammelt hat und
das alles ist vielleicht nur der Anfang
ist es vielleicht ganz normal für eine
Dauer zu arbeiten oder Teil davon zu
sein so wie die Leute hier unter heute
schon ein bisschen kryptowährungen
besitzen die Frage ist ob sie wissen
werden dass es eine Dauer ist es wird
sich eher wie eine Community anfühlen
die eine coole Sache macht
sollte das passieren dann wäre eine DAO
vielleicht bald einfach wie ein eV oder
eine GmbH nur dass der deutsche Staat
noch nicht weiß was das ist
also ich glaube vieles was daraus heute
machen ist nach deutschen rechtstandards
einfach höchst illegal und ich meine
damit illegal nicht werten sondern es
ist einfach nicht so wie das Gesetz ist
vorgesehen hat jetzt sehr sehr schwierig
eine DAO rechtssicher zu machen
das stellen sich Fragen wie wie meldest
du deine Firma an die funktioniert das
mit den Steuern das ist allein deswegen
kompliziert weil daraus oft aus Leuten
bestehen die in allen möglichen Ländern
verteilt sitzen noch ist die Zukunft von
blockchains und daraus nicht gesichert
und auch die Technik ist noch
unausgereift oft langsam und
unzuverlässig ganz zu schweigen davon
dass der kryptomarkt voll ist mit
Spekulanten und Betrügern denn Krypto
ist mittlerweile Big Business und auch
große Geldgeber wollen dort ihre
Interessen verteidigen wenn man heute
bei Youtube irgendwas mit dieser
blockchain Sucht 90% oder vielmehr ist
nur Müll ja es geht nur darum
Spekulationen wie er preissuchen runter
geht nur da investieren digital
investieren kann da investieren kann
schrecklich ja und ich bin immer noch
100 Prozent davon überzeugt dass das die
Zukunft ist also mit ein paar Klicks
einer Firma oder Verein oder
Organisation zu gründen Airbnb nur als
Beispiel Airbnb ist eine Plattform wo
man wohnungsgebieten kann eigentlich
könnte man es auch als Allgemeingut
betrachten was eigentlich den Gästen
oder den Gastgebern gehören sollte und
die bestimmen wie es dir Plattform
weiterentwickelt das wäre eine gute
Gedanke ist die Dauer das richtige
Instrument um sowas wie Airbnb zu bauen
also eine straffe Produktführung und
sowas wie die Welt zu setzen
wahrscheinlich nicht ist eine Dauer was
Gutes um so ein Gemeingut dann zu
verwalten und zu besitzen wahrscheinlich
ja das heutige Organisationen nicht das
nonplus ultra-effizienz und Effektivität
sind ist absolut klar und da glaube ich
können daraus von der Elternvertretung
die sich über Bildung kümmert bis eine
Fahrgemeinschaft bis politischer
konsensmechanismus bist du eine
Werbeagentur bist so eine Band bis wie
teile ich mir ein Patent das aus einem
wissenschaftlichen Projekt rausgekommen
ist ganz viel unbürokratisch leichtes
schnelles effizientes organisieren
ermöglichen sechs Jahre nach dem großen
Fiasko der ersten DAO sind daraus eine
der großen Trends der digitalen Welt
daraus haben aktuell rund eine Million
User weltweit Ende 2021 lagen in den
größten 20 DAOs und 15 Milliarden Euro
in kryptowährungen mehr denn je Glauben
Menschen daran dass wir damit den großen
mächtigen etwas entgegensetzen können
den tech-konzern wie Meter und Google
oder vielleicht ja nur auch den kleinen
mächtigen den Chefs werden die
letztendlich doch noch abgeschafft ich
glaube es wird auch in zehn Jahren noch
Chefs geben es wird unterhalb der Chefs
vielleicht auch eigene daraus innerhalb
eines Unternehmens geben es wird
sicherlich auch Organisationen und
Organisationsformen geben die mit einem
Chef oder ganz vielen Chefs auskommen
und es wird immer auch einen Wettbewerb
der Systeme geben aber vor allem gibt es
hoffentlich auch bis dann ein paar mehr
Chefinnen
nein es wird aber die Option geben sehr
abzuschaffen und das ist eigentlich
schon alles woraus ankommen mittlerweile
gibt es eine Spur wer der Hacker der DAO
gewesen sein könnte aber strafrechtliche
Ermittlung gegen ihn gibt es wohl keine
manche sind sich nicht einmal sicher ob
er überhaupt gegen das Gesetz verstoßen
hat schließlich hat er sich einfach an
den Code gehalten
vielleicht ist an diesem Tag aber noch
etwas anderes passiert nicht einfach nur
ein Krimi sondern ein Test für die
Zukunft das Internets
dezentrale Organisation werden das 21
Jahrhundert prägen internationale
Entwicklerteams mit großen Ideen und
immer mehr Geld all das kommt auf uns zu
Christoph Jentsch und das Team hinter
der Dow waren nur etwas früher dran
[Musik]